but first up he went viral as the
undecided voter in the red sweater who
questioned both Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton at the presidential debate last
year please welcome ken bode a sweater
thank you
[Music]
I requested you that that is your symbol
and I know you I've read your tweets
this week I know you wonder why you're
here yeah for sure I've wondered why
this whole thing happened
well you became sort of emblematic as
the independent voter you were at that
that famous debate and that was all
independents who hadn't made up their
mind and to me you're a gettable voter
I'll be honest with you I have a dog in
this fight I want to convince you that
you should have voted for Hillary
instead of Godzilla well I didn't I'll
tell you that much I didn't vote for
Godzilla I didn't vote for Jill Stein
either not Godzilla in that Jill Stein
are you gonna reveal who you did vote
for now I'm waiting for my book deal to
come through I promised before the
election that I wouldn't say who I voted
for because like it or not we're
obsessed with celebrities in this
country and even like an F list
celebrity like me people put stock in my
opinion and it's not fair to the
democratic process if I tell them what
to believe like you're like you're an
informer that is your job to inform
people educate them entertain them I'm a
random dude that works at the power
plant
people don't need to be informed by me
who did you vote for that was a
wonderful speech Ken but who did you
vote I'm not leaving a money you leave
here at theater you're not getting out
of California my friend it's only an
hour show no really okay you didn't vote
for Trump so you voted you might and you
didn't vote for Jill Stein you didn't
vote for [ __ ] Aleppo dude did you
I've voted for either Johnson or Clinton
or Trump you know one of the big three
well the big two and then the one okay
all right well you keep your secrets
Kent but I wanted to have you here
because you are what I call a gettable
voter you're not totally in the Trump
camp at all I think there are things
that you don't like about him at all and
yet it puzzles me that that you were
still undecided that late and you still
don't want to tell us who you wanted to
vote for and you're the person we need
to get and when I say me we I mean the
Democrats the Liberals if we want to
turn this country around because I think
it's on a very
every bad path what path do you think
the countries on under Trump well one of
the weird things about being undecided
is they ask you like who are you gonna
vote for and that's the last human being
I've ever told who I was gonna vote for
was this person doing the survey to
determine if I could be at the debate
and they said how likely are you to
change your mind and I said I don't know
you know like - probably not gonna
change my mind but I want to keep an
open mind they said well in this super
polarizing election a 2 out of 10
likelihood of changing your mind is
still undecided so there was nobody on
that stage it was above a 4 but I
wouldn't be like 2 in a million if I
guess Donald Trump I can totally
understand that but one of the reasons
why I wanted to wait and make up my mind
you know make my final decision in
Canada you have an 80-day election
campaign and they complain that it's too
long right ours started on November 10th
and it's already going again and people
are like who are you gonna vote for in
2020 I don't want to feed that fire
because that turns our political process
into TMZ it creates people like me and
it creates nothing but sound bites and
sniping back and forth and it doesn't
help solve the issues all right Ken but
we've
[Music]
but we paid for your a Friday are you
gonna answer my question I've been
exposed enough to politics to know how
to knot in okay so just tell me this
what what is it about helices Hillary
Clinton's book is coming out this week
and she made a statement this week which
sounded a lot like something I've said
about her in the past which is future
historians I feel will be very puzzled
at why people hated her as much as they
did I could see not liking her terribly
much because she's not a great
politician but but I mean I've said it
before if you really hate Hillary
Clinton you were molested by a real
estate lady I I just don't get it she's
a bland centrist this is not Che Guevara
in a pantsuit what what about her worked
you so much that you were willing to
just be independent into the last minute
well I never really hated Hillary like I
was you know I'm willing to wait until
the investigations come out on any
charges against anybody because we're
supposed to have this presumption of
innocence especially if you you know
look like you're part of the right
demographic in this country so you know
what does that mean I you have a
presumption of innocence if you're white
people basically according to our
justice system oh it's supposed to be
for everybody and we're working on it
but I give that benefit of the doubt to
everyone and we have trouble extending
that to of polarizing figures like
politicians and even someone who has
moderate or centrist opinions relative
to the Democratic Party like Hillary
Clinton is gonna be a polarizing figure
and people just want to want to jump on
like and Donald Trump was the master of
getting people to look at her instead of
look at him
did that work on you I try to dig a
little deeper you know I don't believe
anything that I hear the first time so
did you think the emails were very
important it was never really a big
issue to me I was willing to let the
investigation play out okay well it did
James Comey got up there and he said we
looked at it he scolded her a little bit
and he said no prosecutor would bring
charges
and then ten days before the election he
brought it up again yeah I thought that
was a really weird move especially since
it looked for all the world like she was
gonna win at that point they're like
right what are you doing why are you
bringing this up if you don't have
anything and then it turned out he
didn't have anything so I still don't
see this incident well what about okay
so what about Russia I saw this we were
off last week and there was a big story
about a focus group that somebody did
and they had voters even the ones who
voted for Trump very disillusioned with
him and then the guy said what about
Russia and you can say about Russia you
think it's something big you don't think
it's something big or you can say I
don't know and every one of the Trump
people said I don't know because when
you watch Fox News you don't know yeah
that's they just don't report it where
do you get your news I try to dig as far
as I can on everything I'll get the
sound bites from Fox News and then I'll
think okay what's wrong with this
particular one and that puts you on the
track that what are we ignoring and then
you can watch your MSNBC s and kind of
get you know you have your Trump or you
have your Fox News way over on the right
then you have your senator and then you
have your your left-wing news you know
they're not quite as far tilted but they
give you leads things are what are we
trying to ignore on both sides so do you
think there is something to the Russia
story
oh absolutely foreign governments have
been messing with each other's political
processes since we invented governments
and by sniping back and forth across the
aisle on this we're putting tools in
their tool belt if we think that Russia
wasn't trying to influence the election
we're crazy and if we think they're not
going to come back and try to do it
again we're even crazier so
[Applause]
and what about Donald Trump who has
admitted to Lester Holt that he fired
James Comey because Comey was looking
into this and he doesn't believe it's a
real story but he's been caught lying
about it time and time and time again I
mean every week we see stuff more that
shows that yes they work colluding with
Russia they were colluding with a
foreign adversary to influence the
election because it helped them isn't
that a deal breaker
I mean well at this point we have the
president that we have you know you
can't go back and make Hillary Clinton
the president and I'm willing to let the
investigation play out but you also have
to keep your eyes open because foreign
governments are going to try to get in
and they're gonna try to influence every
election like if they could come in and
pick the dog catcher in my hometown in
Belleville they will what are you what
when you look back like on President
Obama even President Bush are you
nostalgic for a time when you maybe
weren't so nervous every day I like
President Obama very much oh you did I
voted for Obama once one of the two
times so I don't have any problem
telling all your folks who I voted for
in past election so if you want to come
ask me after the show so you voted for
Mitt Romney you voted for McCain I voted
for McCain I wasn't really a big Sarah
Palin person but in the scheme of things
it only matters if John McCain was you
know ill at the time he wasn't so I was
willing to overlook what I thought was
not the greatest choice for Vice
President and I like John McCain you
know he's a more moderate leaning
Republican and what about like like this
week I saw this quote from Donald Trump
he's talking about his new tax plan you
know when he said it would be the
greatest tax reduction in the history of
our country
everything is always in the history have
you noticed that greater than ever
before you'll see a rocket ship you will
see something happen like you've never
seen before and then be greater than
ever before for me is if like if the
government wants to come and take my
money they're going to but if like if I
had to label myself I'd be a libertarian
but I don't care about if everybody
smokes weed or not so I don't register
with the party but if you want to live
the way you live your life the way you
want to live it
go ahead if you want the government to
stay out of your life that's great but
when the government comes and takes our
money and they're going to let's spend
it a little more responsibility let's
not worry about giving tax breaks to the
very richest people who aren't missing
that money in the first place because
we've proven that that money doesn't
trickle down to me in the upper middle
class it doesn't trickle down to my mom
he's unemployed so maybe we keep their
money and we use it for something good
you're confusing man can you talk and I
said you know this is an intelligent man
this is not somebody who I don't
disrespect I think this man you know he
may be independent thinking which is
good he didn't know who he wanted to
vote for up into the last minute but he
he's a smart guy I don't see why it was
that difficult a choice I'm gonna let
you go I'm gonna ask you one more time
why it was such a difficult choice
because it seemed like this one man is
is preposterous ly unfit for office and
the other lady maybe not the best
candidate but but certainly would have
been a put us in a better place well I
promised myself I would wait until after
the debates to lock in my choice because
there's an where there was news coming
out every day more about one than the
other but there was news coming out
every day and by the time I cast my vote
I was very confident in it I was no
longer even a shade of undecided and
that's about as much as I can tell you
thank you ken bone ken bone the voice of
independent America I appreciate you